myself and those are the people I on his
benefits unless the government cut them
again and the Vista cut nothing with his
talk to work 40 hours and not have the
basic things in life just a really bad
way to live if the cut benefits I would
need a job which pays more than what i'm
getting working 35 hours a week earning
13,000 pounds a year isn't enough from
what pain to supporting family although
he works for a profitable supermarket
chain he relies on seven thousand pounds
of tax credits to supplement his income
but there's got it cut cut cotton me
appear slim credit card need you I don't
him off and the mileage it because I we
need College I'll get left dunno what
that winnicott
I would only have to go Mark's fears
come from predictions that the 12
billion pounds of government cuts in
this week's budget will form people like
him and its cities like Glasgow where
many are in poverty that the impact of
cutting benefits hits especially hard
Glasgow's east end is known for social
deprivation and unemployment but as the
old tower blocks are demolished the face
of poverty here is changing to around
half of all those in poverty now live in
working households they may have jobs
but low-paid insecure ones that mean
they still rely on benefits
but the conservatives message has been
that the road out of welfare is work and
it's one they're sticking to I
understand that I've been lured
headlines and and that is frightening
for some people but this is about making
sure that people are less reliant on
welfare and more independent because
they have more income of their own mint
but paying people enough to live on is
not a legal requirements philco patrick
says it should be even for small
businesses like his which does pay the
living wage people should expect if they
do a 40-hour work and a productive
within that job that they should have
the basic things in life the living
things no it's the living wage and
that's what we believe we believe that
makes a better member of staff and a
more productive member of staff
volunteering at Glasgow project gal Gail
has taught Andrew Moffett new skills
that's led to full-time employment but
still hasn't broken the cycle of welfare
dependency if the government gave the
money that they give me to my employer
my employer paid that money to me I
wouldn't have 2,000 people would have to
be in receipt of benefits and work a
system which is just so stressful to be
borrow that system is about to change
radically in favour the government says
of those who work but for many in
Glasgow work alone is not enough Apple
hirsch steins